four days after Sky News broke the story
of Sue Gray's eye-popping new job that
appointment provoked an urgent question
in the comments this is an exceptional
situation
it is unprecedented with ministers
suggesting she may have broken Civil
Service rules and a key committee could
slow down or even stop her move Jacob
can recommend that no such point will be
appropriate it can go further anger
amongst conservatives is far from
subsiding does this not smash to Pieces
the idea of an independent Civil Service
when we know that one of the most senior
civil servants in the country was
conniving in secret meetings with the
party of opposition labor party Angela
Ray and whilst labor seized on the
opportunity to attack the government I'd
also like to thank members opposite for
asking why a senior civil servant famed
for their integrity and dedication to
Public Service decided to join the party
with a real plan for Britain rather than
Mr Speaker a tired out washed up sleaze
addicted Tory government but not all
conservatives are up for attacking Sue
gray in leaked messages from their what
WhatsApp group former Minister Jackie
Doyle price said a reminder folks Boris
Johnson appointed Sue gray to
investigate partygate no one else so
much for a stitch up he wasn't brought
down by partygate or by Whitehall he
lost the confidence of the Parliamentary
party
former culture secretary Nadine Doris
replied are you serious Jackie permanent
secretaries and civil servants are
Furious the veneer of Defense they were
always able to deploy was their
impartiality written into their code and
as a result their integrity Sue gray has
destroyed that in one Fell Swoop another
MP commented can I suggest we keep
conversations like this off this
WhatsApp group it will leak kirstama's
team privately say they'd always priced
in this reaction but the noise now will
be worth it in the long run but perhaps
their problem is that although there is
little precedent for forcing Sue great
to wait many months to take up her job
Rishi sunak is now under significant
pressure from his own MPS to make an
example of her
while the acaba committee would advise
he must decide that means sugray's
appointment could either be delayed or
possibly blocked entirely Joe Pike Sky
News Westminster